so i have a lot of questions for you
guys uh but i like throwing some
curveballs at the beginning so for all
three of you if you could get the
financing to make anything you want
is there a project that you would love
to make i'm gonna jump in okay i've
always wanted to do a project on the
opium wars like a love story between an
american a new englander and like a the
daughter of like a chinese merchant
trader in the 1840s but you try pitching
that to a studio executive today and all
they can hear are the budget constraints
so
um that's my uh that would be my dream
project if fun finances were unlimited
i'd i'd love to do a very elaborate
period piece i would say that's um
a career goal of mine as an actor or as
a director possibly one day in the
future
um i am currently trying to option
something
that i will not name and um
i would love to be
able to direct it it would be it's also
period so it uh would go up in budget
just because of that and um
fingers crossed because i'm very excited
about it yeah one of the reasons i asked
this question is because there might be
someone watching who's like wait i like
that idea too
and you know it's like putting it into
the ether if you will uh uh jonathan i
am curious when uh kingdom hit netflix
did you all of a sudden notice that
everyone was watching
yes
and you know we we were it's one of the
joys of making a movie like palm trees
and power lines um you know we go off
into these um little corners of the
world
as this um team united around
you know a combination of things but
primarily a script and you know a vision
in this case it was jamie dax's
vision for this film and you go off and
it's this private quiet
little
seed that you kind of plant and tend to
over the course of in this case two
months for kingdom it was a few years
and nobody knows about it nobody's
really seen it the people who have some
understanding of what you're doing are
really excited or incredibly passionate
and then it finds kind of the light of
day when people respond to the work that
you did in that little kind of recess um
of your professional and spiritual um
life it's very gratifying um i mean it's
scary right
and then because it you're releasing it
um but with kingdom nobody
was watching this show and we were
giving everything we had to it um from
kelly sanchez's um you know loss of her
baby to byron's loss of his mother to
matt lauria's loss of his father um
there was a great deal of personal
investment and i think the same can be
said for a story like palm trees and
power lines which makes i think the film
ultimately under jamie's guidance and
and led by
um i think the breathtaking performance
of lily mcinerney um it makes it all the
more potent and beautiful and scary uh
jamie i hate asking the generic thing
but no one watching this will have seen
the movie yet so how how would you like
to describe the film to people the film
is a coming-of-age drama about a teenage
girl during her summer break from high
school
she's in suburbia and experiencing
feelings of suburban malaise she's bored
and aimless and um not fitting in with
her friends and disconnected from her
mother
so all of this sets her up perfectly um
when she meets tom a man who's much
older than her
and she feels that he's kind of
the solution to all of her problems and
is filling a certain need she has but
as the film goes on and um
as their relationship progresses it
becomes clear that um
tom's intentions are not exactly what
they seem
uh lilly uh i am curious this is your
first movie role and i i'm so curious
what what was it like for you actually
being on a movie set versus what you
thought in your mind what it might be
oh that's such a fun question well i
think i got really lucky
that um
we were working with a really small and
intimate crew
so it was kind of the best case scenario
for a first-time actor to kind of not
necessarily ease their way into it
because this role did demand a lot of
pretty heavy emotional
stuff but
it was a really supportive and relaxed
environment to explore all those
different emotions i got to know almost
everybody on set by their name and and
have a little chat every day and i think
that really facilitated um the best work
and the best kind of experience for such
a new actor
uh one of the things that i commend all
of you guys on is that sometimes um i
watch a movie and it feels like it's
been hollywoodized where you know it's
just it's just not real and something
that i felt when i was watching your
film is that i felt like i was almost
wearing an invisibility cloak with these
people watching it as it happened um can
you sort of talk about um how you wanted
aesthetically to tell the story and for
the actors can you sort of talk about
what it was like on set telling this
intimate story
uh yeah i knew that i wanted the story
to be
um
very much grounded in reality which is
perhaps what you're responding to so i
wasn't trying to do anything stylized i
really wanted it to be this one
character's
perspective and i wanted to be with her
every step of the way which meant that
she's literally in every scene of the
movie um
and uh
yeah
yeah i think
jamie did a really amazing job of
directing us um
to have the most sort of organic
and raw kind of
performances we could have possibly have
reached there was a lot of sort of
discovery happening in real time i think
uh as the scenes were playing out
because we did we really intentionally
tried not to over rehearse anything or
um there would be times where jamie
would smack the sides out of my hands
before a scene and say put it down like
you're good you're fine
um i think i have a tendency as an as a
new actor to kind of over prepare so i
is really not to drop the ball
but um for a film like this and
uh
less is more and i think i'm really glad
to hear that that was kind of
translated on screen
you know if if sundance is
um
an opportunity to champion
important stories and new voices and
exciting filmmakers there's just no
better candidate than jamie
um
you know she's the reason why we
all connected um to the script and why
the film is ultimately successful um
i've gotten to work with a lot of really
talented people and there's just such an
effortless connection between
the best filmmakers i've gotten to work
with and actresses i've gotten to work
with and lily and jamie um and i hadn't
really thought about it until just
um
when this film got into sundance but you
know jamie reminds me a lot of getting
to work with like a sofia coppola she's
just fanatical about
the performance and that onset
veracity and all of the all of the kind
of the agility that is required to make
that happen in a pre-production um kind
of rehearsal
um get to know you sort of time
and lily
um you know i i kind of came up with
some wonderful young actresses but the
moment i got to work with lily um
it just became so apparent she breathes
truth i mean there's just nothing that
comes
out of her that isn't honest and
authentic and it reminded me of when i
first
came to la in the early 90s and was in
class with people like kirsten dunst and
lily zobiaski and then more recently
with like a caitlyn deever who i've done
a few projects with you just
you're so grateful to be sitting
literally so close
to that sort of quality of a performance
i mean people pay hundreds of dollars to
do that
in theater and here i get um to get paid
um you know a small amount of money on a
film like this but any you know i i
would pay to be able to sit across from
um that sort of a performance when you
get to be
doing their coverage so
sundance i think really
this is the sort of movie that um i
think speaks to what the mandate is of a
film festival like this
uh i'm just curious lily and uh jamie uh
what does it cost to get uh jonathan to
say these things is it ten dollars or
twenty dollars
oh man
i don't know what we did to uh well no i
i do know what lily did i mean yeah
anyone who sees lily's performance is
going to be blown away i'm confident of
that um
so
i'm gonna start crying
but stephen i mean you know they're
during production jamie's like isn't she
amazing isn't she isn't she incredible
i'm like yeah of course but it's not
like nobody's been surprised by the
success that jamie's had across the
board in the film making and it really
starts um
for us with lily's performance it's just
totally fresh and completely remarkable
and it was not a surprise to any of us
that jamie had the
foresight and the courage to
tell all of these agents and managers
that their hot shot well-known famous
clients who were willing to sacrifice
large paychecks um to be a part of our
project weren't going to get to do it
and that she was going to go with this
fresh face
it turned out it was much more than a
fresh face face as you see in the in the
quality of the work that he puts down on
this film
i i also think there's something about
uh
casting putting someone on screen that
the audience is unfamiliar with because
when you know someone's previous work
you might be associating that actor with
something else
yes uh that's something i talk about a
lot um
i you know not only was it incredibly
exciting to get to you know discover
someone that's as incredible as lily but
i didn't want people to be watching and
go oh they're so and so playing a
teenage girl i thought and i think i was
right that it's um
you know a lot more painful and
um
powerful to be watching and
feel like you're watching this real
teenage girl and not be associating her
with some other role um
so
yeah soon lily won't be able to
um check that box but for this film
yeah i just need to say how grateful i
am to have my first acting experience be
shared with you guys and this incredible
film and
such an incredible
mentor
to me jonathan has been
yeah i learned so much
just watching jonathan and gretchen's
performances in this film it felt like a
master class and and just the most
um
amazing experience i'm so grateful to
you guys and thank you for the kind
words
um i also think something about this
film that um is really really good is
that it's it can show the audience how
easy it is to be exploited and to you
know like because it really takes you
through the stages of grooming and what
really goes on and how someone can
succumb
to
like an outside presence if you will can
maybe if you could talk a little bit
about that uh yeah that i'm so glad to
hear you say that that was critical uh
for me
the script is written actually to follow
the five stages of grooming and i you
know really wanted people to
um be able to understand
um
how leah gets to where she does in the
third act of the film and also in the
very last scene and i felt that in order
for people to
understand they really needed to see
this step by step by step
play by play by play you know
way in which this happens
for uh for you guys um i'm just curious
there are some tough scenes in this uh
for you guys to film and and i'm curious
what was it actually like on set in
between takes because i've spoken to
some actors and they're very jovial on
set in between takes even when it's
serious and others are very much in
their head and i'm curious for both of
you
like what was your head space in between
these scenes and you know and how did
you guys work together because uh some
actors work differently uh i think it
depended on the day
i tend to use levity in uncomfortable
situations and humor to kind of
cope so
i'd say i would be cracking jokes and
trying to keep the atmosphere as light
as possible
on days where we were working with some
of the most intense scenes
other days i
knew that
leah was
going to a place that i couldn't really
um
avoid and i leaned into those feelings
and i guess
took a more kind of
i i don't know um
immersive approach and those were days
where i was just kind of like headphone
headphones on like sulking in a corner
until they rolled
until the cameras started rolling um
but i think jonathan sometimes took this
scenes um at least my scenes
even harder than i did i really felt
kind of
the empathy of
tucker and his character on some of the
harder days
on set
yeah i think i mean you know you want to
throw yourself
into the character and the situation
um
but
when the content is so upsetting
um
it's it's
uh you know you're you're really
fighting between these two
forces
and
um i certainly wrestled with that fought
passionately
with those um different perspectives
and
you know to the credit of lillian and
jamie they were really helpful in just
allowing me to not
feel as
kind of scared and vulnerable
as i i was and had been i think the the
this
there's there's one or two scenes that i
found profoundly
challenging and jamie
was
concerned that i wasn't talking to her
because i was mad at her
i was just
a little too upset by the whole thing to
go back to the traditional convivial
conversations that we have been having
so i love learning about the behind the
scenes of the making of a movie and so
for soon to be fans of the film for each
of you what do you think they might be
surprised to learn about the actual
making of the film i'd say my my 2008
ford crew victoria p 71 police intercept
wasn't just
a stock standard transportation uh
mobile for a number of cast members and
crew but it was also a warming van it
was a place of solace for lily and i and
and it's featured prominently uh from
time to time in the film
yeah good behind the scenes like and
every time you see my crown vic you can
throw back a shot yes
we shot a real working motel um that uh
feels right out of uh you know the a
book like um
uh
nickel and dimed where you see real
families and real people who are trying
to
make ends meet and they're living in a
nightly or weekly low-end
low-income motel space and that was
pretty
sobering for us for trying to shoot a
movie in that world that also is tying
into the
the um you know the reality of that
yeah and that's reminding me just in
terms of jonathan mentioning a location
you know there's over 20 locations in
this film um
people would read the script and be like
oh it's really compact and you know um
actually it was
it required a lot of locations that we
had to find and what i think would be
interesting to someone who um
isn't really working in film is that we
shot
all over the place like so those
locations are our one hour away from
each other but we were able to stitch
them together to feel like one cohesive
world
um i'm fascinated by the editing process
because it's where it all comes together
so i'm curious what was it like when you
first stepped in the editing room uh
were you ready to jump through a window
because you were nervous or were you
like oh we got it i love editing um like
i'm the type of direct like uh i worked
with an amazing editor chris radcliffe
and um we edited together every single
day so i was there every day and
um i love that process and definitely it
can be a little bit scary um
i'll never forget like during the
pandemic when um whenever you'd watch a
youtube video and there would be that um
advertisement for the master class um
thing and martin scorsese would be like
if you don't feel physically ill after
watching your first assembly there's
something wrong and so
you know i knew that even the greats um
you know feel disturbed by their first
cut um so yeah there were things that i
was disturbed by but that's literally
what editing is you know you you
you have to just keep cutting and and um
and it changes so much like there's so
much you can change in the editing room
and so much you can shape and i find it
really exciting it's actually one of my
favorite parts of making a film
did you actually make any big changes in
the editing room that you weren't
expecting
um big changes no
we like there's scenes where we cut
dialogue so like maybe now they only say
three or four lines but originally in
the script there were ten lines um
there's a few little scenes that were
cut entirely from the movie but nothing
they weren't like important they were
kind of just little moments um so and i
think that's fairly normal so no i would
say we didn't make any large changes at
all
uh
jonathan and lily i i'm curious uh what
is it like actually watching
your work and lily especially for you
because you this is your first movie
what what is it actually like watching
it for the first time and can you sort
of take yourself like are you very
self-conscious or can you
you know what i mean yeah
so i was absolutely terrified to watch
it for the first time um i was trying to
think of ways out of it in fact but i
knew it was too important and i was too
invested in the story itself to
skip that um
as soon as i pressed play
i was able to set aside any kind of
insecurities or
you know fixations on my appearance or
my voice all of those things that would
necessarily kind of cringe you out about
yourself on tape and just try to
fall into the narrative as much as i
could so that i could really enjoy the
work that everybody poured into this
right on right down to the pas it felt
like such a kind of family effort so i'm
proud of myself for being able to put my
insecurities aside and and just sort of
enjoy
um or
be moved by the story
i i i'm proud of myself for the way i
coped in the end
i'm not sure i'm going to be re-watching
it necessarily but
um i think you know what what happens on
the set of a confident um artist like
jamie is that your everybody is has
prepared all of their work and then they
come on the day and they
put out a lot of things that are going
to be amazing and
with that are going to be a lot of
things that totally fail and so when you
finally see the the assembly of it um
it's always you're always hoping that
they're picking the right moments and
hunting for the right moments in the
editing bay and then building the
performance around that versus um kind
of
exacting their will on
the the performance based on the script
or based on how they originally
envisioned it
and once you get once you've once that's
kind of satisfied then it's exciting to
see all of the other things that you
hadn't entirely anticipated i mean for
this um character tom i really looked at
like literal red riding hood and
brothers grim sort of aesop fables
cautionary tales
but in the performance itself like on
the day it was all about being the wolf
dressed up in the outfit and looking
lovely and being lovely so then seeing
the f the it all together um
you're like oh those really are
uh no it's not really a nose a better
nose to smell you with or hands to touch
you with it's um it is that wolf in a
sheep's clothing and that's that is
pretty upsetting
on on that note i'm gonna uh you guys
have a premiere to get to and i'm just
gonna say congratulations on the movie
um i thought you guys did such a great
job and i'm really happy to help promote
it on collider
i hope it's a big hit for you guys and
thank you so much for your time
thank you can't wait to again thank you
so much great interview man thank you
you